you know when men flip through the fan
magazines and hit a picture of Anne
Baxter they say AHA now there's a dish
well I would have made a better husband
than that guy holy act and in the same
magazine women say of holy act oh
there's a runner muscle but I bet I
could give him more sweet talk than
Baxter but with all of that and Baxter
and John holy acts seem satisfied and so
is our town present the cartoon and
short subject Awards a pair of people
who have put together a really handsome
marriage John Howe diac and his wife
Anne Baxter
hello happy couple on this one I think
we'd better sort of break up the
speeches alternate John you start oh
wait a minute Paul I know you've been
playing muds in pictures but wouldn't a
real gentleman let the lady start you
know ladies first
a real gentleman would let the lady have
the last word you start Anna the
nominees for the best cartoon are magic
fluke United productions of America
Columbia Stephen boo Sisto executive
producer for sentimental reasons Warner
Brothers cartoons Edward Seltzer
producer catch up your troubles
metro-goldwyn-mayer Fred Quimby producer
and toy tinker's Walt Disney RKO radio
Walt Disney producer the envelope the
winner is for sentimental reasons Warner
Brothers cartoons produced by Edward
ladies and gentlemen the winner for
sentimental reasons
Edward Seltzer producer cartoon you
probably remember it about the little
skunk and the winner seems very happy is
he's accepting his award and I'm very
happy for him that was a wonderful
cartoon I remember it with great
pleasure
those nominated for best achievement in
short subjects one real are aquatic
house party paramount Jack Eaton
producer
roller derby girl paramount Justin
Herman producer so you think you're not
guilty Warner Brothers Gordon
Hollingshead producer and spills and
chills Warner Brothers Walton see aiming
to produce it water tricks
metro-goldwyn-mayer Pete Smith producer
may I have the envelope please mister
open and the winner is aquatic house
party paramount purchased by Jack
I'm winner because
as this one that is not Jackie that is
being accepted by earnest courts in
behalf of Jackie who was the 1943
the Oscar for Jackie the award was
received by mr. Ernest quartz who
directed the picture those nominated for
best achievement in short subjects to
reel our boy and the Eagle RKO radio
William Lasky producer chase of death
Irving Allen productions Irving Allen
producer the grass is always greener
Warner Brothers Gordon Hollingshead
producer snow Carnival Warner Brothers
Gordon Hollingshead producer and Van
Gogh cinema distributors Gaston deal and
Robert Hastings produces mr. Holford the
anvil the winner is Van Gogh phenomena
through videos produced by Gaston deal
and Robertson
another accepting french film
was told by narration while the camera
show
thank you John honey I can and Baxter
and mr. Ned Barisan of cinema
distributors accepted the award now